GBBO S08E03
SANDI IMITATES YORKSHIRE ACCENT:
To think we've had two weeks
in t'Bake Off tent.
Here we are, week three.
Two bakers gone,
now just ten remain.
Grand times.
I don't know why I'm doing
the voice in your head.
I can't do the accent,
keeps coming out a bit Indian.
Well, go to the top of our
stairs, you're here now, lad,
might as well do this.
Welcome to the
Great British Bake Off.
Last time, the bakers
battled biscuits...
SHE GASPS
..Sophie came close again...
I think it's wonderful.
..but it was checkmate to Steven...
That is exceptional.  ..winning Star
Baker for the second week in a row.
SHE GROANS
So frustrating!
Stacey and Flo were at
breaking point...
Ah! Job cracked.
..but it was Chris that folded
under the pressure...
This is so embarrassing.
..and was the second baker
to say goodbye.
Now it's bread week.
What can go wrong?  They'll be taking
on a signature tea-time classic...
Ah! They've sunk.  ..getting stuck
into the technical...
Two fingers.
I just know how Paul does it.
..and going all-out to attempt...
I've never baked a dragon before.
..the toughest bread sculpture
challenge ever set on the Bake Off.
I feel like you're trying
to psych me out.
I quite like this accent, I might
stick with it, go up the path,
and 'ave a bath.  Really suits you.
What about you, could
you pretend to be well-bred?
Actually, I am well-bred,
I just pretend to be
a street urchin, you know,
give me a bit of an edge.
Check this out.
HE IMITATES POSH ACCENT:
Toodle-pip, everyone,
and welcome to bread week.
This is probably the week
I've been...dreading!
Bread's not my forte.
I love bread and I can't wait
to get on with it.
I've been making bread
for about 40 years.
I've said that now.
I hope they turn out good today!
I love bread, but I make
it for my family,
I don't make it for
Mr Paul Hollywood.
I hope I haven't peaked because I
really would like Star Baker again -
it's kind of addictive.
Morning, lovely bakers,
welcome to bread week.
Today, Prue and Paul would like
you to make 12 teacakes.
Your teacakes need to be round,
they need to be identical,
made with an enriched dough,
and your fruit of choice
needs to be evenly distributed.
You can serve them
with accompaniments.
Maybe a jazz singer.
Yeah, that'd be nice,
or just jam is fine, too.
You've got 2 hours 45 minutes.
On your marks.  Get set.
Bake!
This is the biggest week for me.
It's my chance to show them
that I can bake bread.
Still a bit nervous, I'm not
a great one for bread week.
We don't make a lot of
bread at home.
Fingers crossed,
I've tried these quite a lot,
so everyone at home
is absolutely sick of teacakes.
Teacakes are made from
an enriched dough,
which contains extra fats, eggs,
sugars and fruit, all of which
can inhibit the yeast,
preventing the all-important rise.
With an enriched dough,
they have two prove it for
a little bit longer
because it's full of butter,
so it will rise more slowly.
If they under-prove, the dough
will be very tight inside.
If they over-prove,
it'll just basically flatten
out like a pancake.
Some of the bakers will do very
unusual flavours, I'm sure,
and I love that. I don't think
I should have a closed mind,
however much I like
a traditional teacake.
They can put cranberries in there,
sultanas, mixed peel.
As long as it tastes sweet
and delicious,
and spread out equally amongst the
whole teacake, I'll be happy.
I've got me milk on to boil,
so I'm making blueberry and cardamom
teacakes, with, like,
cinnamon through it as well,
just because it's all the flavours
of, like, sticky buns, you know
those cinnamon buns that you get?
Like, they're like my
favourite thing.
Back home in Liverpool,
Kate often bakes bread and cakes
for a local homeless charity.
She's filling her teacakes
with dried blueberries
and infused spices.
That's gone a bit wrong.
No, I'm going to start this again
because my hob turned off
and now my butter's gone weird.
Oh!
I think they have too much clo...
Ugh!
Hello, Liam.  Morning.  Morning.
Tell us about your teacake.
So I actually didn't know
what a teacake was.
Have you never had one?  No.
So I was, like, OK,
something that's remotely similar is
my nan's Jamaican Easter bun.
Liam's been following his nan's
recipes since he was 15.
His homage to her Jamaican roots
will be packed with
cherries and raisins
and made with a dough infused with a
stout he's just old enough to drink.
What sort of texture are
we expecting inside?
Teacake texture.
Right, and that is...?
Very nice.
THEY LAUGH
I'm just putting the milk
in the dough,
see if I can get it the
right consistency.
Oh, that's nice! That is nice.
So I'm making a kind of
Dutch-Nordic-inspired teacake.
Go, James!  Playing to the crowd.
James is no stranger to
trying something new.
At home, he has a lengthy to-do list
of bakes he'd like to master.
Today, he can tick off fruited
teacakes, with cardamom, citrus,
and infused dried fruit to give
them a Nordic twist.
What makes a good teacake?
Well, I don't like teacakes,
to be honest.
I think they're the poor
cousin of the hot-cross bun.
You are joking, aren't you?  No.
These are great for, like,
a lunchtime snack...  Lunchtime?!
Well, in the Nordics.  You can't
tell cos of the light in there,
you can't really tell if it's
morning, evening, night or what.
Don't you start with your
anti-Scandinavian nonsense!
Oh, I love a bit of kneading.
Cos you don't have
to go to the gym.
As well as providing a workout,
kneading creates the gluten
that gives dough its strength
and structure.
Without enough kneading, the bakers'
teacakes will be dense and flat.
Lots of people say,
"Oh, if you're really angry,
"like, knead and put
your anger in the dough,"
but I always feel like I can't do
that because I love my dough.
You think, "I love you, I love you!"
Julia's been married to husband
Matt for three years.
It's her English mother-in-law's
love of toasted teacakes
that's inspired her Earl Grey-infused
apricot and cherry version.
Just need to get the dough proving
as quick as possible.
I just want to get it right.
Cos rushing too much creates
panic, doesn't it?
Who needs panic? Nobody.
I call them my tagine teacakes
because they are based on the
leftovers that I had from a tagine.
All the ingredients, minus the lamb.
Trainee stuntwoman Sophie started
baking six years ago
when she left the Army and
the officers' mess behind
and finally got her own kitchen.
Her tagine-inspired teacakes will
be filled with spiced dates,
almonds and apricots.
You're a stuntwoman, aren't you?
You can probably do
stunt falls, can't you?
Rolls.  Combat roll, I used to...
Combat roll, do you learn
that at stunt school?
Erm, I actually learnt that
when I was doing judo.
They call it a break fall.
Judo, very similar to comedy.
First day at comedy
school, banana skin.
Of course!
Once the bakers feel their
dough's kneaded enough...
I like the feel of it,
when it changes from this, like,
gloopy mess into a nice silky ball.
..the dough needs to prove.
Prove that for about 45 minutes.
This is going to prove for an hour.
It's a waiting game now, just
waiting for it all to prove.
What have you put yours on?  One.
Half.  See, I've put mine on 30.
30?  It's on holiday in there!
SHE LAUGHS
Holidaying in Greece!
Steven comes from a family where
recipe books are piled high.
He's hoping for a hat-trick
of Star Baker crowns.
He's going all out with his
Madras cocktail teacakes
flavoured with orange and cranberry
and with a unique accompaniment.
So this is vodka butter.
The vodka is purely there
to lift flavour.
Oh, I can taste it.
This is called keri no chundo, it's
the equivalent of mango chutney.
My friend's mum has this for
breakfast every morning.
She likes it a bit more spicier than
I'm going to present it
because I don't want to
blow their heads off.
After an unconventional commute home
from work, Yan loves to bake bread.
Her spicy keri no chundo will
accompany her honey-glazed
masala-chai teacakes.
You've got a little bit of
an injury there.
Yeah.  Is that a baking injury?
No, it's a scooting injury.
I fell off my scooter.
What, like a moped?
No, a...
A children's scooter?
It's an...
Little bit embarrassing.
Little bit embarrassing!
Maybe you need to take some
tips from Sophie.
Cos, you know, she's a stuntwoman,
so she can do those stunt falls.
Tuck and roll?  Yeah, the tuck and
roll.  Well, this is a minor injury,
could have been worse.  No, that's
not bad, actually.  That's not bad.
It makes you look a little bit,
you know, dangerous, a bit edgy!
You're so edgy, Yan!
I quite like doing these bread
cos it's nice and quiet.
Aw, I don't know, this makes me
nervous, the sort of sitting around.
Everything makes me nervous.
Back in her own kitchen,
Flo loves to share her 40 years of
baking knowledge with granddaughter
Lydia.  That's the
Elvis Presley quiff.
She's making spiced
mixed-fruit teacakes
served with orange and whisky jam.
I feel terrible sitting down here.
With one hour of the bake
already gone...
I feel as if I'm doing nothing.
..the bakers need to manage
their time carefully.
It's definitely grown.
I think mine's ready.  Spend too much
time on their first prove
and they won't have enough
for the second.
I can't leave it in
there any longer.
I think another five minutes,
then I'll stretch it out,
get the fruit in there, cos I think
the second prove's more important,
as you're making the actual
shapes of the buns, so...
Now I'm introducing
the dried fruits,
the cranberry and the orange zest.
The only thing that
I always stuff up on
is my fruit being
evenly distributed.
The thing is with adding fruit now,
it's not easy to mix it in
because it all just falls out.
I've rolled it up like
a sausage roll
to try and get it quite
even to start with,
then it's just a lot of kneading.
Ensuring their teacakes are
all the same size
is about attention to detail.
You've got to get them
as even as possible, really,
so that they cook evenly
in the oven.
Pretty straightforward -
what can go wrong?
If the fruit pokes through,
it tends to catch in the oven.
I'm sort of smoothing the dough,
pushing it round, tucking it under,
so all the fruit's in the middle.
I didn't even know what a teacake
was cos in Scotland a teacake is,
like, a mallow thing
with chocolate and a biscuit.
Tom's homeland may have denied him
a lifetime of fruited teacakes
but it's given him plenty of lochs
to swim in at the weekends.
Agh!
He's making a cranberry
and orange fruited teacake,
and for extra sweetness he's adding
chunks of white chocolate.
You've managed very well
to have your fruit hidden.
Is there any fruit in there?
There are. I hate when
you get a teacake
and you get a little cranberry or
something that's like a bullet.
I actually think it looks like a
good teacake when you've got a bit
of fruit on the top, personally,
but who am I to judge?
Ooh, that's good.
Stacey makes bread every
week for her family.
She's channelling all the flavours
of Christmas with her cranberry and
cinnamon teacakes.  Are you
egg-washing these before they go in
the oven?  I'm putting a bit of milk
on the top and it makes them nice
and soft.  You put milk on the top?
Right, bakers, you've got one hour
left, 60 good teacaking minutes.
That is really not a
long enough time.  Ooh!
The addition of fruit means
the second prove will take longer.
I'm going to leave it in for as long
as I can before they have to go into
the oven.  How are we supposed to
prove two in the proving drawer?
I'm stacking them, with bowls.
SHE GASPS
Oh, dammit!
Almost had squashed ones.
Instead of perilously stacking
in the proving drawer,
Steven's opted to use somewhere that
already has more shelves.
Hopefully in this
proving oven, that should
be all right.  More waiting.
HE CHUCKLES
Hello, Flo.  Hello.
So you can have a little
rest now, can't you?
I can, yep. Can't be doing
with clock-watching.
Wow.  I never time a cake or nothing.
All in here?  Mm.
That's magic, isn't it?
Mmm. Yes.
Do you just get a sense, a feel?
Yeah. Yeah.  A touch.
Ah. Not all the time.
Didn't last week!
HE LAUGHS
There's 30 minutes, bakers,
just 30 minutes left!
Great.
To avoid under-baked teacakes,
judging the precise moment
to stop proving
and start baking is critical.
I'm going to go in in
five minutes, you know.
Ah...  You all right there, mate?
Mine are going in.  You're going in?
I'm going in. They look big enough.
These have not had
long enough to prove.
Yep. Come on, bad boys.
Oh, mine are huge.
They haven't rised as much as
I wanted to, but, like,
you've just got to crack on.
I'm egg-washing the teacakes
so they come out nice and shiny.
I'm putting a bit of milk on the top
and it makes them nice and soft.
Argh, they've sunk, they've sunk!
They just... The proving, I think
they've just proved too quickly
and they've gone, "Bleurgh."
15 minutes, bakers, 15 minutes!
Right, they'll go in for 15.
Going in, OK?
I've put them in at 190.
I have 160.
You're 160?  I went 160.
160? That's low.
I don't know whether to do 180.
Do what you normally do,
don't listen to me, sorry.
Oh, I don't know now!
It's the blind leading the blind.
How long have we had, do you know?
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have five minutes!
They're not going to be ready.
I'm coming out, I'm coming out,
I'm coming out.
Mine aren't ready,
so I'm not taking them out.
They're looking fabulous. I think
I'm going to get one tray out.
Oh, my days.
They're going to cut into it and
it's going to be raw. Aw, I'm dead.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Oh...  One minute!  Ooh...
I actually think they're ready.
Ow! They're hot. Ow!
SHE GASPS
Jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam...
Oh, thank you, lovely.
Do you want me to put these in?
Put them on the top.
Bakers, your time's up!
Step away from your teacakes!
LIAM SIGHS
The bakers' teacakes will now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue.
I think they're a bit small.
I think teacakes should be
big and flat.
These are sort of buns.
Good fruit distribution in there.
I think you have slightly
over baked them.
Yeah.  I get the blueberry,
I get the cinnamon.
They taste terrific.
Thank you.  Nice...  Thank you.
..buns.
SHE GIGGLES
Great texture.  Thank you.
The proving is perfect.
And the baking is perfect.
It's got good flavour.
That tastes fantastic.
Yeah.  You just need that temperature
to be up by 20 degrees.
That's fair enough.  And you ended
up with the perfect teacakes.
Congratulations.
Brilliant, thank you.
Handshake from me.
Thanks very much.  Means nothing.
These two look heavily fruited,
and these don't.
They might not be when
you open them,
but the truth is it's
better not to have these outside,
because they get a bit
too overcooked.
My problem is, is
I don't think it's baked.
Oh, no.
It's not baked.  That's not good.
Have you got any
salt in there?  Yeah.
Yeah, a little bit of salt.
Not enough.
It's bland.  Bland.  Do you know,
I think you could have done
with a bit more fruit in here.
What temperature was your oven?
160.  Too low.
Smells great.
Actually, I quite like it.  Yeah?
Yeah, I do. The thing it needs,
though, is more spice.
Oh, really? OK.  Yeah.
It just lacks flavour, but actually
the fruit is lovely.
I think it's clever of you
to have rolled them,
so that the fruit is really encased.
Never got any fruit in that one.
LAUGHTER
But the flavour of the dough is
excellent, and that balances it out,
so by the time you've toasted it and
put your butter on, it tastes good.
That's the closest thing I've
had to a teacake so far.
I think you baked it OK.
I honestly think it's
a good teacake.
It looks like a teacake, it feels
like a teacake, it's not hard.
I think your choice of milk
was a big problem.
Yeah.  Because if you'd had egg on
that, they'd look as they should.
I know.  But you've
got the basic shape,
and you've got a decent teacake.
There seems to be plenty
of fruit in there.
I'm certainly getting the fruit, and
certainly getting the orange.
Spices, yeah, I'm getting that too.
Overall, I think the flavour's good,
distribution's good, the size is OK,
just slightly under proved.  OK.
It's a little doughy, isn't it?
It's the volume of fruit, and
it's added all the moisture to it.
But overall
the flavour's nice, you know?
It does have a very
good flavour, though.
What else is in the mango?
Cardamom, cumin, chilli.
It's amazing, there's so
many things going on.
Beautiful chutney.  And a
little bit of a kick at the end.
I didn't want to blow your
heads off.
That's great.  It's delicious.
Thank you.  Very, very good.
Really delicious.
They, my friend,
are not your finest hour.
They are pretty bad.
It's just over proved.
Because you've heated it up,
the whole thing's fallen apart,
you know.  Yeah.
On the other hand, your vodka
cocktail looks absolutely wonderful.
You know what, it's
absolutely delicious!
Try a bit of vodka butter, Paul,
see if you change your mind!
THEY CHUCKLE
They're still over proved!
I got my negative feedback
that I've been waiting for.
I think he referred to it
as "not my finest hour."
It was really disappointing.
By far my worst bake
in the tent, hands down.
I need to come, like, top three
in the Technical, or, like,
I'm in trouble.
I do feel relieved,
yeah, definitely.
Just looking forward to the
Technical now.
I mean, I think for someone who has
never really eaten a teacake,
for Paul to say it was the
closest thing to teacake
he'd had so far was,
that was pretty good.
I would very much like them to say,
"Wow, you've nailed it."
That's what I want,
Hasn't happened yet.
NOEL:  Bread week isn't about
to get any easier.
The bakers could practice for
their first challenge,
but not for the next one.
And they're tackling another classic
in the world of great British bread.
Right, bakers, it's time for your
Technical Challenge,
which, surprise, surprise,
has been set for you today by Paul.
Paul, any words of wisdom?
We expect perfection.
No pressure.
I'm going to have to ask you two
lovelies to leave, sorry.
Off you go.
It's all right,
they're going drag racing.
Yeah, it's the Prue Paul Drag Race.
That is the pun to end all puns!
LAUGHTER
Right, for your Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you today to
make a cottage loaf.
Now, the cottage loaf, the history
of it, dates back hundreds of years,
to a time we call PM,
pre-mixer, so you are going to be
making your dough by hand.
You've got 2.5 hours.
On your marks...  Get set...
BOTH:  Bake!
Lovely jubbly.
Cottage loaves have been baked in
Britain for hundreds of years.
Oh, my God, something I know.
I'm just so pleased I
know what it is.
I kind of know what I'm doing.
But not all our bakers have this
loaf in their repertoire.
I've not made one before.
It is very daunting.
I don't bake a lot of bread.
What can go wrong?
Apart from everything.
Why have you set a cottage loaf
for a challenge?
These are the best amateur bakers
Great Britain has to offer,
so I expect them to be able to
make a decent cottage loaf.
What I want to see is the smaller
piece of dough on the top,
but not too small, larger on the
bottom, good, even colour,
and good slashes all the way around.
What can go wrong, Paul?
Shaping, obviously,
is the key point,
because you've got to be able to
bond the top and the bottom.
If they don't, the bottom
will blow off the top,
so the top will literally fall off.
So it's all about making both
the balls quite tight,
and the way that you do that,
and the way I do it is just
drive my finger right the way
through to the tray underneath.
Do you flour your finger?
HE SNIGGERS
You must, otherwise it would
just stick to the dough!
I could oil it!
Make a dough!
That's it, that's all we get.
The instructions are pretty vague,
so I'm just trying to get as much
liquid into it as possible,
without it becoming like sloppy.
I've never made one before
in my life,
so I've gone for the rubbing in the
lard, don't know if that's right.
I'm going to make the basic dough,
flour, salty-ish water.
If you put too much water in it,
it goes drunk,
what I've experienced loads!
When I've made it once before,
the little one on top, lid, off.
Obviously, I've got a lot to
make up for from this morning.
Making the dough by hand.
Oh, my God.
It is quite a long process.
My muscles are aching so bad.
I'm knackered.
If it's not kneaded enough,
it just loses all its shape.
I don't know if that's
right or not, but...
It feels like it should
feel, I guess?
I can't really afford to
leave it much longer.
It's all about time management.
I'm just about to
do the window pane test.
If it doesn't get a hole in it, that
means the gluten's developed enough.
If you can stretch it, I can
say it's almost ready, so...
30 more seconds for luck.
It's going into its first prove.
I love Paul's
instructions, don't you?
Prove. Do it.
He hasn't given us any info.
Prove it for 40 minutes.
We're going to do it
for about an hour.
Play it by ear.
45 and check it.
If the dough doesn't prove enough,
the loaf won't come up and rise.
What I want is double in size.
The dough's in the proving drawer,
so we just wait.
I feel, like, heart racy.
This is horrible.
Are you enjoying bread week?
So far, so good.  Yeah, you
like bread, don't you?
Yeah, I love bread, but I do
know what a cottage loaf is,
I have made one before.
That's an advantage.
You said that like you didn't.
No, I have made one before.
I do know what it is.
I have seen one, I made one.
I've made one before.
Yeah? Prove it.
SHE LAUGHS
We're going to moonwalk out of here.
See you later.  Good luck.
I'm taking out.
It's the art of actually knowing
when it feels right, whether it's
proved right, and I just
haven't got the experience.
Would you take that out now?
What do you reckon?  I'm going to
leave it with you, my love.
I'm quite happy with it.
Looks good, risen well.
All right.
The instructions say divide the
dough, and shape into two balls,
one small and one large.
How much I'm going to split it,
am I going to split it 500, 225,
or am I going to split it...
I just don't know yet.
Take about a third, I think.
A quarter?
Divide by three.
I'm not weighing it,
I'm just doing it by eye.
No-one had scales, electric
scales, in a cottage.
"Shape into a classic cottage loaf."
And that's about as much
instruction as we've got.
So I'm just shaping the dough,
otherwise it will kind of wonk over.
You don't want wonky balls.
You can't help but look around.
Paul wants it perfect, and this
isn't looking that perfect.
Maybe this should have been smaller.
That doesn't seem right.
What Paul does is he sticks his
fingers in the flour,
and he
goes down like that.
Two fingers.
Up and down like that.
I just know how Paul does it.
That just looks wrong and weird.
Put your finger in it.
I'm just going to stick with it.
Slash your dough, any way you like,
I guess.
The instructions say prove.
So this is going to go back
into the proving drawer.
The second proof is really
important,
because it's what gives the
final loaf its structure.
It may work, it may not.
My heart is...POOF.
Bakers, you have
45 minutes left, 45!
Take it out, the second prove.
It's not horrific.
If that's not right,
then I don't know what is.
Very happy with that.
I just want to make it perfect.
That looks like BB8
out of Star Wars.
Oh, well.
Not happy.
Oh, gawd. Look at my cowpat!
It's turned into just one loaf.
I think the dough was too wet,
so it kind of spread.
The instructions say "bake".
Hot water in the pan,
creating a bit of steam-age.
Wish me luck.
Baking it at 170, but I might
have to turn it up.
I'll probably do, like, ten minutes
high, and then drop it down.
Fingers crossed.
How long are you going
to bake it for?
30, 35 minutes, but I'm going to
watch it like a hawk.
I'm trying to send vibes.
"Become more beautiful."
Talking about the bread.
The longer it's in there,
the longer mine's hid.
Why?  The bottom of my bread has
eaten the top of my bread.
What can you do?
Nick someone else's?
You'll be fine.
Inside, I'm crying.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes
left for your cottage loaf.
It doesn't seem to be going brown,
it's going to take a while.
Not a great sign, is it?
I hope the clouds are not
a reflection of Paul's mood,
I'll put it that way.
I'm happy it hasn't gone like that.
I just hope it doesn't go zzzzup.
I'm frightened in case it
goes pffft.
Oh, God!  What's up?
It's fallen off the top!
It just fell off! Oh, my God!
It's ruined. It just, like, died.
I feel sick.
Oh, my God, I'm dying inside.
Do you know what,
it's not the worst.
It's just all about
not being the worst.
I feel like I'm in trouble.
Bakers, you have five minutes.
Say something urgent.  Left!
You've got five minutes left!
Seriously?
Five minutes?
Mine's raw.
I've just put the oven back
up a little bit,
because it's not quite dark enough.
It's the highest temperature
possible, just to give it...
Bang.  I'm hoping it goes POOOF!
And blossoms.
I don't think it's cooked.
I know it's not cooked.
Tick, tick, tick, tick...
My God! It's actually
sliding more down.
I'm going to wait until
the last minute.
Bakers, you've got one minute left!
OK, go!
That's definitely not cooked.
You see, mine's done.
I'm taking it out the
last 30 seconds.
It's going to be tight.
OK, bakers, your time's up, please
bring up your cottage loaves.
It's just a disaster.
Paul and Prue want to see
a classic cottage loaf,
well risen with a rounded bottom,
and a honey coloured,
crusty exterior.
They have no idea whose
loaf is whose.
Let's start from this one over here.
The actual shape of it, the
way it sits, is good.
There's a little bit of decoration
on there, which is good.
And a nice rounded bottom.
It's quite risen.
It's proved well, but
it's slightly under baked.
Good flavour.
Overall, not bad at all.
Paul, I really do like this one,
it's been properly pushed together.
There is a nice shape.
I do like the big cuts
in it, as well.
Let's have a look at it inside.
It is baked, it's crispy.
When you're making a big loaf, you
can afford to have some crust,
and it's worth it,
because it's lovely.
I think it's a
really satisfactory loaf.
OK, next one.
That doesn't look as if it's
risen at all.
I think a little bit
more proving might have helped.
It's a bit soft, it needed ten, 15,
maybe even 20 minutes
still in the oven.
It's coming out too early, what
happens is the dough then rests,
and then concertinas down
onto the bottom.
Right, moving on to this.
The actual shape, but it is central,
it hasn't ripped either way.
It's got a little bit of
a crisp there.
If that had another ten minutes,
it would be perfectly crisp,
wouldn't it?
Yeah. OK, next one.
The actual overall
proportions are right.
Very nice.  The flavour's good.
But it would be nicer if
it had more crust.
Right, moving on.
It's just not been put on straight.
Normally, you'd push your finger
right the way through from the top
to the bottom, and that allows the
dough to become straighter.
Yes, this didn't get the finger
treatment, at all.
Next one. The overall shape is good.
It's stayed in the middle.
It's really under baked.
Yeah, it is.
And you can still feel it's full
of moisture, it's a wet loaf
Right, moving on to this.
The whole thing's merged
together to create a big cob
You've lost that top.
The dough itself was a bit too wet,
it doesn't look like
a cottage loaf at all.
Very neat, I quite like the
look of that one.
The proportions are right.
And actually the height as well,
you see the way it folds in.
It' lost a bit of definition
on the top, but it's still there.
It's quite light, too.
Enough salt. Flavour's good.
It's a decent loaf, that one.
OK, last, the colour's good,
but the one on the top
is almost like a pancake
sitting on top of the cob.
Texture's a bit tough,
it's a bit flat.
Paul and Prue must now rank the
loaves from worst to best.
In tenth place, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Kate, it's slightly wobbly, though,
and it has a soggy middle.
In ninth place is this one.
Whose is this? You've lost all the
definition in it.
Yan is eighth,
Flo is seventh,
Sophie sixth,
Liam fifth,
and Tom is fourth.
And third place is this one,
whose is this?
Beautiful shape. I like the
flour, very, very neatly done.
I like that. Thank you.
In second place...
Beautifully risen, it would have
been a great loaf
if you'd left it in the
oven a bit longer.
So, in 1st place is this one.
APPLAUSE
Good definition, nice and round,
good, strong, shaping.
Very good.
First in the Technical on
bread week, I mean, that is massive!
So excited!
My dough ate itself,
which wasn't a good look.
I was surprised I wasn't
last, to be fair.
Oh, what a disaster.
I hope there's some redemption
there from this morning.
You can be confident,
and you know the bake,
but you don't know which way
that dough's going to go.
It's got a mind of its own.
I've got to actually smash it
tomorrow, that's all I've got to do.
Just smash it tomorrow,
and I should be fine.
NOEL:  There's one challenge left
before Paul and Prue decide
who's destined for Star Baker
and who will be leaving the tent.
For me, the most surprising thing
is the way bread week
has simply blown it wide open.
I thought I had a good idea of who
was doing well, Steven particularly.
He did OK in the technical.
Then you look at his teacakes,
they were massively over proved
and it was such a shame. Two star
bakers on the bounce, that's...
That's a difficult place
to fall from.
Can we talk about Flo
for a brief moment?
Oh, lovely Flo.  She's been in a sort
of middling area the whole time.
She has and she struggled
in the technical as well,
so she's in trouble.
She has known every time that
that wasn't the best she can do.
And I think Liam's in some danger
because yesterday,
he didn't have a good day.
He just needs to do well today.
Yeah.
I think three of them,
at the moment, look very safe.
Julia I think's done well.
Tom's done well.
Stacey's done really well.
I'd like to see her do well
in the show stopper
because she's set herself up to be,
you know, a Star Baker, she has.
The Bread Queen.  Yeah,
she's in a very strong position.
Wow, that makes it quite exciting.
Just a touch!
Well, morning, bakers. Welcome
to your Showstopper Challenge.
Now, for today's challenge,
Prue and Paul would like you
to make a bread sculpture,
but not just any bread sculpture -
a coloured bread sculpture.
We want eye-catching designs
using natural ingredients
to create flavour and colour.
Channel Jackson Pollock.
Right, you've got
four and a half hours.
On your marks.  Get set.
BOTH: Bake!
This is big. This challenge is big.
I've got to smash this in order
to get into safety mode.
Just trying to stay calm,
do the best I can.
NOEL:  The bakers not only have
to produce a bread sculpture,
they have to showcase a minimum
of three naturally
occurring colourings.
Beetroot just, like, gives a
really, really nice vibrant colour.
I've got spinach and parsley.
And I'm adding it to
obviously make a green colour.
I'm flavouring it and colouring it
with some squid ink.
PAUL:  When you're introducing
colour to a dough,
it's all about balance.
Beetroot, turmeric, chocolate,
you've got to add them in
in such proportions
it doesn't inhibit the yeast
too much, and that's the trick.
PRUE:  I mean, to impress us,
it's got to look amazing
with as vibrant a colour
as you can get.
And every bit of it
has got to taste good.
All right, Flo?  Hello.  Hello, Flo.
Now is that activated charcoal
or is it..?
No, it's squid ink.  Squid ink.
Oh, squid ink.  Yes.
It's going to be
Davy Jones's locker.
Davy Jones's locker?  Yeah.
Flo's pirate-themed sculpture
will be made from one
basic white bread dough
coloured and flavoured
with squid ink,
beetroot and paprika.
That's a good idea.  That's a nice
idea.  And I hope it turns out well.
I hope so.  Thank you.
Hope I do something right!
Don't be like that, it's all right.
Well done, Flo.  OK.
NOEL: Flo isn't the only baker
going for a nautical theme.
I'm doing a squid ink
and smoked garlic octopus.
Kate's octopus will take centre
stage in her undersea sculpture,
resting on a spicy twisted
red seaweed bread
with an accompanying
green spirulina bread.
I like flavours of the sea,
so I wanted to do something
that all, like, tied in together.
And I think it works
quite well as a concept.
I've never made a bread
sculpture in my life.
So... Especially,
when I saw coloured bread,
I was like, "OK, cool,
food colouring."
But when I saw "naturally" I was
like, "Eurgh... That's even worse."
Liam plans to shape his bread
into an ice cream sculpture.
His three doughs will be
coloured and flavoured
with apricot, beetroot
and cocoa.
I am in a precarious position.
Kind of wish I'd made more bread,
but I can't help
what's not my thing.
So I am doing a picnic basket,
so I've got a dough
for the basket itself.
Then I've got, like,
a baguette poking out of it,
so that's a separate dough.
Bunch of grapes.
And some apples and a sort
of tea towel, if I have time.
Sophie's trying to give her
sculpture an Italian colour scheme,
with a white basket,
green bread apples
filled with apple compote
and red beetroot bread grapes.
A lot of time's taken up
with the sort of kneading
and preparing the doughs, so I think
that'll be sort of priority,
just try and get that done
as quickly as I can.
SANDI: As if delivering
three different
coloured breads wasn't enough...
JULIA SINGS
..Julia has decided
her sculpture needs four.
I'm making kind of a scene, so it's
like bit of a grass on the bottom,
mushroom in the middle
and snail on the side.
You've got quite a lot to do, then.
I've practised it about...
Not a lot, only about, like,
six, seven times.
It's a big thing to do, isn't it,
six or seven times?
Julia's flora and fauna will sit on
a spinach and parsley forest floor.
A red pepper and paprika bread snail
will shelter under a mushroom
with a potato and beetroot bread cap
and a Russian black rye bread stalk.
Tell me about this
black Russian bread.
Basically, it's traditional bread
that I always had.
I've kind of changed the recipe
a little bit.
I'm adding black treacle to it and
I've put some malt in it as well.
I love the sound of it.
It's quite complicated.
We want you to do well, don't we?
Absolutely, yes.  We don't want
to send you home, or the snail.
Good luck to you.  Can't send snails
home, that's the thing.  Thank you.
I've got three different
doughs to do.
We're going to have a raisin
and walnut saffron loaf,
which is the milk steeping here.
So this will turn
a bit more yellowy.
So it'll be... I'm making an owl, so
it'll be like a tawny owl type body.
And if I've got leftover dough,
a couple of hedgehogs.
A hot chocolate
chilli bread will form
the head and wings of James's owl,
which will nestle
in the branches
of green tea
baguettes.
Now I've just got to make sure it
all stands up.
And the head doesn't fall off.
But apart from that, it's simple!
SANDI: For her sculpture,
Stacey's turning to a traditional
family recipe.
My main bread is a challah.
This is a Jewish bread.
It takes quite a while, a challah.
I mean, really, I like to prove
my dough overnight.
But I have done it in the time
before and it's fine.
Sporting a challah bread brim,
Stacey's hat will
have a crown
of woven turmeric
and lemon bread
and come adorned
with a variety
of coloured
breadsticks.
Are we going to get some good tastes
in this as well? Not just look good.
I know, well, the thing is -
I want it to taste good,
but I wasn't actually going
for the flavours in the colour,
I was going for colour.
If the basic bread is delicious
anyway, it's fine.  Yeah.
It's nowhere near as pink
as it is normally at home.
Don't want to put any
more beetroot in it,
cos I think it'll make it too moist.
And too heavy for the yeast.
So, erm... I think I might
make this again.
Tom's planning a floral bouquet of
beetroot and turmeric bread roses
nestling in a
pesto breadbasket.
I'm going to keep this dough,
I'm going to prove it,
as I would the other one.
I'm just going to see if the
other one gives me a better colour,
because it's got to be
a nice vibrant colour
to look like a flower.
FLO:  Look at that!
Nice that. It's a good prove.
SANDI: After the first prove,
the bakers can start shaping
their dough into their sculptures.
To get it right, Yan has been
practising using modelling dough
borrowed from her niece's toy box.
Wow!  The sculpture is called
Basil the Vegetarian Dragon and his
Pumpkin Hoard. No meat involved!
I can't see how anyone's
going to beat that
unless someone does
a gluten-intolerant unicorn.
Yan's dragon will be made
from a basil and spinach bread
with turmeric and
tomato coloured pumpkins,
a host of sweet and
savoury toadstools,
all resting on a
coriander focaccia floor.
My superpower is probably,
apart from baking, obviously,
is time management.
And in my head I can do this
in four hours and 30...
Four hours and 15 minutes
is my target.
Got 15 minutes to spare.
Before they can shape their dough,
the bakers need to incorporate
any ingredients they're using
to further flavour them.
Now this is the caramelised onion
and goat cheese.
The compote's got apple
and cinnamon mainly.
This is stuffed with chorizo,
Manchego, onions and garlic.
I don't want to disappoint today.
I really hope I don't.
There's a lot of flavours going on.
Morning.  Hi, Steven.
Good morning.
Tell us about your bread sculpture.
I'm making a handbag.
You're making a handbag?
Steven's handbag will be made of a
Manchego, chorizo and sherry bread,
adorned with a curried
breadstick chain
and a chocolate and
peppermint handle.
You've struggled a little bit
on the bread week so far.
Yeah, yesterday was...was
quite painful actually.
So it's really important
that this one works.
It's important... Just not that
it works as bread,
but that the flavours are good.
I'm just shaping the octopus now.
I'm making a snail.
That just looks inappropriate.
At the moment, it looks
a bit like a chicken.
That's why I need that model.
The second dough
is not quite the right colour.
So I'm just actually going
with the first one.
It's very fiddly.
I feel like you're trying
to psych me out.
Super stressy.
NOEL:  Bakers, you are
halfway through!
Is this what it's like being you?
Good, isn't it?  Yeah, it's weird
down here. I like it.
Your roots have...
well, they want doing.
This is ready to go in the oven now,
which I'm very pleased about.
If the bread doesn't hold
its shape whilst baking,
then their structures will collapse.
Ooh, that one...
I've never baked a dragon before.
Please work!
This is the ugliest snail
I've ever made.
I'm going to make a couple
of little hedgehogs.
Trying to do a pirate's hat.
This is like a Noddy's hat.
Cos the light colour
can go really dark,
so I've made a little owl chest
plate for him and little sunglasses.
Please be nice, please be nice.
Mine's a disgrace.
I'm going home.
LIAM:  I'm out. Game over, kid.
It's done.
Some of them sort of,
like, tipped over, so...
One hour left, bakers,
just one hour.
An hour?  Yay, it looks like an owl!
I'm really quite pleased
with that actually, yeah,
I'm just going to give it
a Paul Hollywood tap.
It's not too bad.
It's the best I can do, anyway.
I've still got about 20-something
roses to make.
How many doughs are you in?
This is my fourth.
Ooh!
With at least three different types
of bread to bake
and only one oven...
Everything I'm doing, everything,
is on different temperatures,
so I've got to remember to turn it
up, got to remember to turn it down.
Right, they'll go in
for about 25 minutes.
..time management is crucial.
Have to move really quickly
with these because
literally one minute and they catch.
This is my mushroom.
Yeah, it seems to be OK.
So this one is
the focaccia forest floor.
It's a nice green, though, innit?
Not bad at all.
Now my challah's going in.
See you soon!
Hello, mate. You all right?
Emotional. Like, crazy, bro, like.
Really? Are you all right
though, now?
Yeah, I'm good. I'm good.
I mean, sometimes I just have
to have self belief.
I couldn't boil an egg at your age.
I'm not too sure I can do that now!
No, I'm joking!
Bakers, you've got ten minutes left.
Ten minutes.
This is where the trouble starts.
The bread's a little bit softer than
it was when I was practising
but it doesn't look like
it's going to collapse.
This is so stressful.
OK. Three, two, one, go.
Bakers, you've got
five minutes left!
Just hating my pirate's hat.
Not happy.
Bakers, time's up.
Please place your bakes
at the end of your stations.
Some of them are marvellous,
aren't they?
It's judgment time
for the bread sculptures.
Each must showcase a minimum
of three natural colourings.
It's a pity he's like a baby dragon.
I would have liked to see him
really centre stage.
Paul's going to pull his head off.
I think you've got some
strong bold flavours.
The basil's there.  It's very good.
Tastes just like pesto.
Great flavour. Wow.
I think we'll try the pumpkin.
It's well baked. I love the colour.
I'm trying to hunt the flavour.
I'm not getting much.
I get the chilli heat,
but I'm not getting much else.
Let's try this focaccia.
Garlic.
Strong.
Almost too strong.  Mm.
It's not very evenly distributed,
the apricots.
OK.  The flavour of the apricot
is delicious.
What's in this chocolate one?
Um, so it's chocolate and date.
Your flavours are fantastic today.
Get in!  But your proving
is little bit under.  OK.
I like the design of the owl.
The hedgehogs, probably not as much.
This is walnut and raisin, isn't it?
Yes, it is.  Smells good.
Saffron's quite strong.
The walnut and raisin is losing
its battle against the saffron,
which is a real shame.
Remind me what the green is?
It's matcha green tea.
Oh, it's matcha.
Do you know,
that's too strong for me, too.
I really don't like
the flavours, James.
Yeah.  But the design is so bold,
the baking is so good,
the proving is right...
..you've got everything right,
except it doesn't taste nice.
Do you know, I think it
is so elegantly done.
It's exquisite.  Thank you.
I'm going to take a little cut
of the challah.
While I'm here...  Yes.
..I'll take a little bit
of the lemon and turmeric.
Challah is lovely.
Really good.
The tastes all right, but the
proving's wrong. It needed longer.
The strength of that turmeric
is quite overwhelming.
Now, the lemon's lost.
I think the design's good,
I think it's been executed well,
but your flavours are wrong.
Wow.
Well, Steven, that is amazing.
It does look mighty impressive.
I'm going to have to destroy
this now, you know.  It's fine.
I think that's unbelievable.
The delicacy of the crumb,
which is more focaccia-like,
the flavours that you've got
from the manchego,
from the chorizo... Well done.
I mean, that's a big tick.
I've got to find the weak link.
It's delicious.
It's a perfect breadstick,
just curly.
Remind me of this one again.
It's a peppermint...
A chocolate peppermint breadstick.
It's lovely.  I mean, wow, wow, wow
on the flavours.
Steven, come here a second.
Amazing.  Come here.
Stand next to Prue. I'm going
to go and sit down here.
LAUGHTER
That is ridiculous.
Thank you, Flo. Can you tell us a
little about your coloured breads?
It's supposed to be Tom Jones's...
Tom Jones? Davy Jones's locker.
I think Tom Jones's locker
would not look like that.
Davy Jones's locker!
I think it's very ingenious.
I think it's a little too clumsy
to come off perfectly.
Oh, look at the colour.
There's your three right there.
Squid ink, turmeric and beetroot.
The texture's very good. It's baked
well cos it's more like a ciabatta.
Is that what you set out to do?
No.  You could've lied then, Flo.
I left the door open.
You never walked through.  No.
The paprika is quite strong
in there.
This one tastes almost tasteless
because my mouth is still burning
from the paprika.
The paprika's just overwhelming.
Not your best, Flo.  No.
I love that octopus.
I love the flavour of squid ink,
so I hope we're going to get it.
The squid ink comes through,
and it's very suitable
for an octopus.
That is very good.
Heavy crust. All the way around,
which cracks.
It's beautiful, and
a regular structure inside.
Well done.
I do like the basket. I think
the plaiting is very, very good.
I'm looking for the definition in
the colour and I'm not seeing it
too much at the moment.
The apples don't really look
that green, do they?
The dough's quite underdone.
I think it's only marginally
underdone.
And although of course the apple
inside has made it a bit wet,
it's still very pleasant to eat.
Well, you've certainly got your
three colours, haven't you?
But having said that, it was about
getting the definition in the rose,
and I think you've lost
some of the definition.
And the definition on
the yellow roses is much better.
Much better, yeah.  I mean that
is really quite exquisite.
This is the...  Beetroot one.
I mean, there's this little pink
hue, which is what you're going for.
Yeah, what you're aiming at.
Not much flavour. Quite bland,
which is a shame.
I like the snail.
Is there something about the shape
of the snail that particularly...
LAUGHTER
Paul, are you going
to pull yourself together?  Yeah.
Give me a minute.
Well, you certainly have
the three colours, don't you?
In fact, you have four colours.
Beetroot and potato.
Oh, just feels so lovely.
Look at that.  The colour
of that is amazing.
Lovely texture.  Nice flavour.
I'd like to try this.
This is the rye.  Wow.
Oh, that's packing a punch,
isn't it?
This is going to be fascinating.
Good crust.
Very malty.  Great texture,
great flavour.
Really good bread. All right, now
we're going to attack this fellow.
Look at that. It's goat's cheese
and...
Caramelized onion.
Great taste.
Really fantastic taste.
The goat's cheese in there
is delicious.
Your design is very, very good.
Well thought through.  Well done.
Thank you so much.  Thank you.
What a memorable Showstopper.
Who stood out for you?
Stacey's fallen out of the
possibility of Star Baker.
I don't think that was good enough.
I think Julia's certainly
still up there.
Julia's was lovely.
The snail was humorous,
with the goat's cheese inside
and the onion.
It was delicious.  She gave herself a
huge job and she pulled it off.
Obviously, Steven stood out.
That was exceptional.
I mean, every single element to that
was perfection.
The flavour combinations were
stunning.
Very, very clever.
Though I'm not sure we could give
him Star Baker when he did so badly
with his teacakes.
Can we talk about
Flo and Tom Jones' locker?
The paprika burnt your mouth.
It just killed everything.
There's so much paprika in there.
She's in trouble.
I think she struggled, Flo.
What about Liam?
I want to shake Liam because he
keeps doing things wrong,
but he has this brave thing
about flavour, which I love.
Has he saved himself? I don't know.
Do you think that you two are going
to be in agreement about who's going
to be Star Baker and who's going to
be saying goodbye?
I think so.  I think we might not!
I'm sure we will.  In the end.
Right.
NOEL:  I've seen them, they
arm-wrestle.  I know.
I have to say, that's the best Bread
Week I've ever seen.
Well done.
I have the lovely chore of
announcing who the Star Baker is.
The Star Baker this week is the
person who put the "tea" into teacake
and whose Showstopper was from
Russia with love.
It's Julia.
Well done.
That leaves me with the horrible job
of revealing
who's going to leave us.
And the person that we have to say
goodbye to is...
Flo.  Yeah.  I'm sorry.
All right.  Have a hug.  Fine.
Honest to God, I'm fine with it.
Let me get myself together.
I will really miss Flo.
I'm a little bit sad that she's
gone, actually,
because I think the world of Flo.
I've enjoyed the ride.
I've met some lovely people
and I'll remember that for the rest
of my life.
I'm glad to get back to normal life.
It is exhausting!
I thought I was going.
I need to up the levels a bit.
I've got to do better.
Julia is the deserved Star Baker on
Bread Week.
She was incredibly ambitious.
I did not expect that whatsoever.
It was exhausting!
I think it will be good for Steven
to realise
that he's not going to dominate.
You know, there are other bakers
there beginning to gnaw at his
ankles a little bit and I think
Julia's one of those.
I needed to come down off my little
cloud.
I've got to practise.
I'm heading back home tonight and
the oven's going on.
Next time...
Something smells burning.
..a Bake Off first...
Oh, my God!  ..Caramel Week...
It's a beautiful thing,
but it will destroy you.
..with a super-sweet signature.
Can you really eat that much
caramel?
A double Dutch technical.
What the hell does that mean?
And a Showstopper so sticky...
It's all just melting.
..it spins the bakers.
Do not move.  ..into a sugar frenzy.
The judges are not going to like any
of that.
Subtitles by Ericsson